vor wenigen tagen wurde der kamikaze
satellit wie fett in den orbit gestartet
er soll eines der größten probleme der
raumfahrt lösen weltraumschrott der müll
im orbit der erde bedroht die raumfahrt
immer mehr und könnten die letztlich
sogar unmöglich machen eine von ihm
ausgelöste kettenreaktion wäre das ende
der raumfahrt der kleine satellit soll
jetzt ausprobieren wie weltraumschrott
in zukunft verhindert werden kann jetzt
endlich zum 20 herzlich willkommen im
weltraum droht eine riesige katastrophe
dass kessler syndrom eine
weltraumschrott kettenreaktion bei der
am ende nahezu sämtliche satelliten im
orbit erde zerstört würden am schluss
wären dann so viele trümmer in der
erdumlaufbahn statt raketen gar nicht
mehr gestartet werden könnten eine
schale aus weltraumschrott rund um die
erde würde das verhindern ständig
passiert dieser größte anzunehmende
unfall
es gab bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit
der erde und jeder erzeugt wieder neuen
schrott in brüssel schweren geschäft 166
millionen trümmerteile um die erde
spektakulärster unfall bisher 2009
stoßen der us-satellit nummer 33 der
willigen telefonnetzes gewicht eine
halbe tonne und der russische satellit
cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer
aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund 40000
kilometern bleibt von beiden satellit
nichts mehr übrig außer rund 100.000
schrottteilen sie haben jetzt die
chancen für den nächsten unfall deutlich
erhöht zum beispiel eine kollision mit
der asf der internationalen raumstation
wie hier am 24
2015 ein teil dieser koalition steuert
mit hoher geschwindigkeit auf die iss zu
es stammt eben vom russischen satelliten
kosmos 2251 entstand also eben bei
diesem unfall die nasa kann eine schwere
beschädigung der station nicht
ausschließen
die abfahrten werden in zwei an die hff
angedockten russischen sojus kapseln
evakuiert im fall der katastrophe
könnten wir sofort abdocken und zur erde
zurückfliegen
der weltraumschrott muss weniger werden
und deshalb wird jetzt mit dem
satelliten hieß es eine neue methode
getestet satellitenbilder aus dem orbit
zu entfernen dabei hätte die tat ein
sehr einfaches prinzip an dem kleinen
satelliten ist
ein feststoff triebwerk montiert das den
satelliten wieder zurück zur erde
bringen soll und ihm dann mit hoher
geschwindigkeit so tief in die
atmosphäre einfach und lässt dass er
vergnügt es gebe so keinen wert auf
schrott das würde zwar nicht die 166
millionen schotten aus dem orbit
entsorgen aber dafür sorgen dass es
nicht mehr werden dabei ist die technik
vergleichbar simpel und dass es extrem
wichtig der antrieb ist ein vollkommen
autonomes element das technisch nächsten
mit dem satelliten verbunden es wird
komplett autark gesteuert so dass er
selbst ausgefallenen satelliten wieder
zurück zur erde bringen kann so dass sie
vergnügen der feststoff hat den vorteil
lange lagerfähig zu sein und so auch
noch nach jahrzehnten zu zünden wäre die
ideale lösung zur entsorgung von
satelliten dieses entsorgungs element
würde einfach dazu gekauft werden und
dann am ende des einsatzes gezündet
werden also dazu gekauft von den
erbauern des satelliten gelingt der test
soll ab 2015 jeder philipp damit
ausgestattet werden sodass die zunahme
des weltraumschrott es ab diesem datum
deutlich gebremst wird jetzt kommt es
darauf an dass der existierende schrott
in zukunft effektiv entsorgt wird wenn
es dazu etwas neues gibt dann erhalte
ich euch natürlich hier auf dem
laufenden wenn nichts dazu verpassen
wollt dann durch mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den aus die
blogger hier geht es weiter mit neues
zeitalter der raumfahrt eingeleitet
neues pay sex report einfach
draufklicken und falls euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran